MURDERING, AND AS OMAR JIMENEZ
REPORTS FROM GREENWOOD, INDIANA,
THAT MAN IS NOW BEING HAILED AS
A HERO.
>> IT'S BECOME AN ALMOST
FAMILIAR SCENE OF EVACUATION IN
AMERICA.
>> WE WERE IN THE FOOD COURT,
AND WE HEARD LOUD GUNSHOTS.
>> AS AN INDIANA SHOPPING MALL
BECAME AMONG THE LATEST SETTINGS
FOR A MASS SHOOTING.
MONDAY, THE POLICE CHIEF
ANNOUNCED THE IDENTITY OF THE
SUSPECTED GUNMAN.
20-YEAR-OLD JONATHAN SAPIRMAN
WHO POLICE SAY ENTERED THE MALL
AT 4:54 P.M.
>> HE WALKS DIRECTLY TO THE FOOD
COURT RESTROOM.
HE ENTERS THE RESTROOM AND
SHOOTS VICTOR GOMEZ OUTSIDE OF
THE RESTROOM.
HE THEN POINTS HIS RIFLE INTO
THE FOOD COURT WHERE PEDRO AND
ROSA PENITA WERE EATING DINNER
AND SHOT BOTH ROSA AND PEDRO.
>> ACCORDING TO POLICE, HE SHOT
AND KILLED THREE PEOPLE SUNDAY
EVENING, USING A RIFLE.
VICTOR GOMEZ, ROSA RIVERA, AND
PEDRO PINERA.
HE INJURED TWO OTHERS INCLUDING
A 12-YEAR-OLD GIRL AT THE MALL
JUST OUTSIDE INDIANAPOLIS.
AND THEN POLICE SAY LESS THAN
TWO MINUTES AFTER THE SHOOTING
BEGAN, THE ATTACKER WAS KILLED
BY A, QUOTE, GOOD SAMARITAN WITH
A LAWFULLY CARRIED GUN.
>> THE SHOOTER FIRED SEVERAL
ROUNDS, STRIEGING THE SUSPECT.
THE SUSPECT ATTEMPTING TO
RETREAT BACK INTO THE RESTROOM.
AND FAILED.
>> WE'RE VERY THANKFUL FOR A
YOUNG 22-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO
STOPPED THIS VIOLENT ACT.
>> AND THAT'S RELATIVELY RARE.
ACCORDING TO AN ANALYSIS
PUBLISHED BY "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," THERE WERE AT LEAST 433
ACTIVE SHOOTER ATTACKS FROM 2000
TO 2021.
OF THOSE, JUST 22 ENDED WITH AN
ARMED BYSTANDER SHOOTING THE
ATTACKER.
AND OF THOSE 22, TEN WERE FROM A
SECURITY GUARD OR OFF-DUTY
OFFICER.
COUNTRYWIDE THIS YEAR, THERE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MORE THAN 350
MASS SHOOTINGS WHERE FOUR OR
MORE PEOPLE WERE SHOT, ACCORDING
TO THE GUN VIOLENCE ARCHIVE.
THIS ONE, LIKE MANY DO, STRIKING
AT THE CORE OF NORMALCY.
>> IT'S LIKE ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
FUN.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE GOING
SHOPPING.
>> AND EVERYONE THAT DAY THOUGHT
THEY WOULD BE GOING SHOPPING.
EVERYONE EXCEPT FOR MAYBE ONE
PERSON.
POLICE SAY THE SHOOTING SUSPECT
ARRIVED AT THE MALL WITH THREE
WEAPONS TOTAL, TWO RIFLES AND A
PISTOL.
MORE THAN 100 ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION, ONLY USED ONE OF THE
RIFLES DURING THE SHOOTING, AND
AS FOR THE GOOD SAMARITAN, THE
POLICE CHIEF SAYS IT DIDN'T
APPEAR THEY HAD TRAINING B